you are new to the Marvel family you are
returning to the Marvel family so what
was it like for you coming back where's
nebula at and if you can give us a quick
intro to Manton for those Marvel fans
may not be familiar with in your honor
it was amazing coming back I had such a
good time on the first film and I had so
much fun playing nebula this kind of
like evil villain character but this may
be to come back in a bigger more
significant capacity and also just
explore why she's so evil and why she
might be considered a villain we're like
chipping away at the layers and the
exterior now which is great so I'm an
alien and I have empathic power if I
touch them when I can feel their
feelings and change them and I grew up
pretty much on my own I arrived in the
movie at the same time as Kurt Russell's
character I'm a little bit like a child
you know I discover things for the first
time and I'm just not really used to
interact with people so you know bring
some fun stuff to listen how do you
think nebula would react to Memphis
trying to a second with her don't think
nebula would be okay with mansis
touching any part of break my hand I
feel like yes you would just like quick
shoot off your hands and then wear it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know each other each of your
characters is kind of an outside
perspective when it comes to the
Guardians and yet here you are
interacting with this crazy group of
characters it's the most difficult for
you to each relate to I'm going to say
nebulas pretty confused by mantis
they're sort of polar opposites mantis
is this lovely innocent creature and
then nebula doesn't get and what about
mantis
I think rocket I mean an ambulance
because she she never reconnects with
her so you know they were so different
and she's so strong and she's so lonely
and a rocket to she find him cute so
here you stand here a garden of the
galaxy guardians of the galaxy
why would we be the guardians of the
[Music]